y reino unido da un paso adelante para
conseguir una nueva herramienta contra
el coronavirus el país es el primero en
aprobar el uso de emergencia al
tratamiento de la farmacéutica
estadounidense merck la píldora llamada
montura bird es un medicamento para
prevenir los síntomas graves del cobi 19
shahab goldberg tener un fármaco como
éste tener un antiviral que sea potente
que se pueda tomar por vía oral es un
momento muy importante y marca un hito
en nuestro descubrimiento de
medicamentos efectivos contra el cobre
19 será aplicado a pacientes positivos
que presenten factores de riesgo como
edad avanzada complicaciones cardíacas
obesidad o diabetes el fármaco podría
reducir a la mitad las posibilidades de
muerte u hospitalización según los
estudios de la farmacéutica por el
momento no está claro cuándo llegarán
las primeras dosis al país entretanto la
agencia europea de medicamentos dijo
estar lista para aconsejar a los países
del bloque el uso de emergencia del
móvil
intentaremos acelerar nuestra evaluación
para llegar a una autorización lo antes
posible porque estamos entrando o ya
estamos en la cuarta ola de esta
pandemia
distante tras la recomendación del ente
reguladores serán los estados quienes
decidan utilizar o no el medicamento
las acciones de merck han subido como la
espuma su popularidad también crecido
después de que la compañía anunciara que
compartirá la fórmula de la píldora con
múltiples firmas para hacer llegar
rápidamente el medicamento a países con
pocos recursos